- [Lecturer] What we're gonna
talk about in this video
is how political and cultural events
might have an influence on
someone's political ideology.
So let's make this a little bit concrete
and political scientists
will sometimes have
various classifications
for these types of effects.
So for example, there is
something known as generational
effects, and these would
be events that affect an
entire generation, that
could influence how an entire
generation thinks about their
position on different issues.
An example of that might
be if you were to grow up
or if you were an adult
during the Great Depression
in the 1930s, well that might
affect you in many, many
different ways.
You would start to maybe be
a little bit conservative
with your own personal finances
realizing that a rainy day
might come one day.
Many people who grew up
during the Great Depression
viewed FDR, Franklin
Roosevelt, as a major factor
in taking the country out
of the Great Depression.
Other folks might disagree
with that position.
But if you were one of those
folks who believed that FDR
through the expansion of
government helped bring
the country out of the Great
Depression, and if you believe
that FDR was a good leader
for the United States
during World War Two, well
then, you might lean Democrat.
You might lean Democrat
the rest of your life.
And it indeed seems to be
the case that many people
who grew during the Great
Depression did indeed
lean Democrat because
of their belief that FDR
was good for the country.
Similarly, if you grew
up during the Cold War
or if you were an adult during
the Cold War you had this
thing hanging over you
in the 60s, 70s, and 80s
of what would a nuclear war
with the Soviet Union look like?
And so many of those folks
might look at someone
like a Ronald Reagan, who
many people would argue
helped bring about the
end of the Cold War.
And so many of these folks
who did view Ronald Reagan
as a major actor there
might lean Republican.
Or even if they don't lean Republican
they might say, hey, the
type of strong muscular
military presence with
diplomacy that Ronald Reagan did
well, that's a type of point
of view that I support.
Now these two things were
big, macro events that would
have happened over many,
many years, if not decades.
But there could also be particular events
and sometimes particular political events
that might influence
someone's political ideology.
So let me write this
down, political events.
And so an example of that
might be the Watergate Scandal
under Richard Nixon.
Many of the people who were
adults then and understood
what was going on, it
might have led to a general
distrust in government.
It might have led to a more
of a belief that people
in high office do things
without telling us.
Once again, these are not,
it's not gonna be everyone
who lived in that time
period, but it might make some
folks lean one direction or another.
Now everything I've talked
about has been in the realm
of politics, but there is
also a lot that happens
in culture that could
affect your ideology.
If you see more of a certain
point of view on television
for example or in movies,
that might make you more
sympathetic to that point of view.
You also have effects over
the course of your life
that affect your ideology.
And so these are often
known as lifecycle effects.
Lifecycle effects.
And this is the idea that
as you go from being young
to getting older, just
different things in your life
might make you lean in
one direction or another.
And these are going to
be broad generalizations
but let's say you are
young, you are in college,
you have a lot of student
debt, you might lean
maybe toward a more progressive
candidate or have liberal
leanings if a candidate
says hey, the government's
going to try to reduce
student debt or provide more
support for young students.
But then as you get older and
maybe you become a homeowner
maybe you have more wealth,
you have a higher income,
you might say, hey, these
taxes really hurt more
than I suspected and they're
quite large, or maybe you're
starting a business or you're
saying, hey, these regulations
really aren't as good as an
idea as I thought they were
when I was young, well then
maybe you might, and I'd
stress might, you might start
leaning more conservative.
So I'll leave you there.
The big picture is is that
your political ideology
isn't just driven by your
genetics or your family
and we've talked about
these in other videos,
or where you grew up.
So not just driven by geography,
it's driven by a whole
set of things, many of the
things that might happen
to you individually, let's
say you had a bad incident
with crime that might
make you tougher on crime.
Or maybe you were on the
other side, you got arrested
for something you didn't
do, that might change your
point of view, and things
that happen on a bigger scale,
things that might happen
to your entire generation.